Hello everybody and welcome to episode
number nine of my road to one build
series. Uh which is kind of a little bit
more of a progress video, but we will
get to the uh grinding the money out in
a little bit. Uh but we need to get our
account set up and that is going to take
a bit of time. Uh in the background, you
can see I'm just combining some sets.
You may have seen it in my most recent
moneymaking episode. Um but for this
episode, we are mainly going to be
focusing on quests. There's going to be
a drop party in it, but mostly we're
going to get quests done. We're going to
get Monkey Madness done. And yeah, kind
of excited to get some progress done.
Let's get started. I'm actually really
impressed by how fast these things sell.
I'm going to be getting about 250k on
each set. Um, it's only been like a
minute or so so far. I checked on G
Tracker. It's like says like 11 or 15 an
hour, but still actually seem to be
coming through a bit quicker than that.
At least in my experience so far. Uh, so
we got one sold and we're just kind of
waiting on the other one, which should
be any minute now. uh 512k and we
invested about 5 mil into it. So, pretty
good way to start off the episode. I
like to include a little bit of money
making at the beginning. Uh but like I
said, as we get further on in the
series, uh we'll definitely focus down a
bit more on that. Uh should be any
second now. We're going to sell it. And
there we go. So, room set sold. And that
is 512k in profit. Uh so, like I said
earlier, we are trying to get our attack
to 60 so we can get the dragon scitar uh
once we finish monkey madness. So,
there's 55 attack. We're gonna get
around 58 or 59. Uh then the experience
from the quest will actually get us to
60, which is kind of cool. Uh but we
can't forget our strength as well. We
got to level that up for the max hit, of
course. Um we're about to hit 55. Uh
we're just going to leave our defense as
it is so far cuz once we finish Monkey
Madness, we'll get like five or six
defense levels anyway. Uh so we're just
going to wait and then afterwards, uh
we'll train that up because in the end,
we are actually wanting to focus our
defense because we're going for Zelra.
Um, but to do that we need higher melees
and it's more efficient just to do it
this way. Um, but yeah, there's 55
strength. Um, so we're kind of just
waiting for the drop party to start. So
we just kind of decided we're going to
do a little bit of slayer. Uh, and we
got Ankus as a task, so not too bad.
Okay, this should be our last Anku. Um,
it would be kind of nice if we got more
of them. We only got 26, but anyway. Uh,
there's our 17th task in a row. Okay, if
we get something good, I will do the
next one. Uh, oh, hill giants. Yeah,
that's pretty good. We'll definitely do
hill giants. Okay, so we finished
slaying those hill giants. It's uh
pretty quick. I didn't get a club,
unfortunately. Or a key. And we got rock
slugs. I don't really want to do those
now. I think we're just going to start
some quests instead.
Yeah. Nah, I don't want to do that.
Okay, we actually just got a farming
level. So, we got level 48 farming,
which is kind of nice. I think this
should be our last um crop for our run.
Like always, we got 40 seeds and we're
going to get about 200 250 minars uh for
about 800 to 1 million profit. So again,
just raking in the cash from the
farming. And like I said earlier, we're
going to start some quests. So um we're
going to start by doing Doric's quest,
uh which conveniently gets you to level
10 mining, which is a requirement for
uh I can't remember the quest name, but
it gets you to 29 smithing. It's pretty
classic one. It's really, really good to
do early on. Uh but this is kind of an
easy way to do it. Yes, we'll start with
Dork's quest. Okay, this is probably the
quickest quest of all time. There we go.
1,300 mining experience, which gets you
exactly the level 10. And now we can
start um you know you know the quest I'm
talking about. Okay, we're just talking
to the squire to start the quest. Uh
which I still did not look at, but we'll
figure it out eventually. Uh the one
with the blurr. You know what I'm
talking about. Okay, there we go. We're
just about to get the blurrite ore. Uh
one of my favorite part like places in
the game actually. Blurite ore is always
so classic. 2005 when I started playing
getting that blur sword was just such an
achievement. And now I just realized it
kind of sucks ass. But you know, times
kind of change. Okay, there we go. It
was the night sword was the name of the
quest. Uh, but it gets you right to 29
smithing. So, would highly recommend to
do that early. Just smashed my hand
against my drawer. Um, but anyway,
besides that, good experience. So, we
got about 20 to half an hour left uh
before this drop party is happening. Uh,
organized by James at G Tracker. Um, but
everyone that was in the clan chat was
able to come, I believe. And yeah, so
what we're going to do here is we're
going to get uh 30 fire making so we can
start the sea slug quest. Um these are
just kind of randomly being done for no
particular reason, but eventually I will
need the stats and I just kind of feel
like doing some quests today. Okay,
there's 15 firemaking. Probably took
about 5 minutes or so. Uh we can burn
oak logs now. Okay, there we go. We are
just about to hit level 30 fire making.
That probably took 10 minutes.
Firemaking is an extremely quick skill.
Uh but yeah, now we got the prerequisite
for sea slug. So I've actually never
done this quest before. Uh so be kind of
interesting for me to do. Um pretty sure
the only reason you do it is for the
fishing experience. And so you might as
well do it when you're at level one
fishing already. Uh cuz I think it'll
get me to mid20s. Uh which I mean it's
just saving me time. This is kind of an
interesting cut scene. And he's gone.
Okay, that was a pretty quick quest
actually. We're pretty well done. Uh
let's see what fishing level that
actually gets us to. 7.1k flipping or
flipping experience. Fishing experience.
That would be cool if you get experience
in flipping. I got to level 24. So, not
bad. Okay, we're at the drop party and
there's actually a shitload of people
here. Uh, good amount of them following
me for some reason. Um, but yeah, I did
not expect there's no chance of me
getting anything. So, it's it's cool,
but not going to get anything anymore
for sure. Oh my god, there's even more
people in here. Oh my god. I don't even
know where they're going to drop
anything. There's there must be like
couple hundred people here for sure. And
dragon play legs. I don't know how the
best way to do this is. I've tried
staying on the same spot and just hoping
someone appears below me. Um because Oh,
that guy just got some. Yeah, running
around and trying to pick stuff up does
not work. So, we're just going to sit
here and spam click for a little bit and
see what happens. Still nothing. But you
know what? It's it's kind of cool just
seeing everyone here. Again, thank you
for everyone actually showed up. If
you're wondering what this is from, it
was um kind of event hosted by the guy
who owns GT Tracker. Um but everyone in
my CC showed up as well. So I don't know
if anyone actually got anything, but
it's still kind of kind of cool just
seeing the community of people around.
Um but I don't think I'm going to end up
getting anything here. I'm just going to
sit here and click for a bit longer. But
um yeah, but there's some pretty low
odds going on. Oh,
there was a whip on the ground. Ah, why'
I even bother? Okay, so it's actually
been two days since that drop party
happened. Uh, it was a lot of fun. So,
thanks for everyone who actually showed
up. Uh, but now we have been grinding
these sand crabs super hard. We're
actually up to 58 attack and 63
strength. I think uh it was my days off,
so of course I was still playing a
little bit. Um, but yeah, for the most
part, I was AFK training this whole
time. So, we're pretty much ready to
start Monkey Badness at any time. Um,
we're at 58 attack because the
experience for monkey bandness will get
us to 60. And, uh, we should get some
defense levels as well. And we actually
had some Renars in our bank as well. Uh,
so we're going to sell these off for
another 1.7 mil just before we start the
quest. I'm bringing our cash stack up to
about 8 mil, which is actually pretty
decent. Again, we'll be focused on this
a little bit more after we finish these
quests. got our account leveled up a
bit. Uh but 8 mil not too bad. Okay, we
got everything for the quest bot I
believe. Um so now we have to do it.
Unfortunately, that part is going to be
the longer part. Ah, so I thought OS
Buddy actually had an inbuilt thing to
solve this puzzle for you, but maybe it
only happens for the clue scroll
puzzles.
Um so I think I'm just going to do this.
I mean, you can pay 200k to skip it. Um
but I don't think it'll take me more
than 10 or 15 minutes. So, I think my
time I think it's still worth my time to
do the puzzle. Okay, we finished the
puzzle. And actually, I think that was
like a new personal record. I did that
in like six minutes. Not to brag at all,
but um I suck at every other aspect of
the game. Uh but I can [__] do those
puzzles. That uh seagull in the
background seems to be kind of
struggling to get anywhere.
But yeah, we're off to a patrol. So,
this part is one of the more frustrating
ones. I always [__] it up somehow. Um,
but you have to wait for the monkey to
uh turn his back and then sometimes
he'll turn back around and punch you in
the face. Uh, but mostly you can escape.
See, we're going to try to pick the
lock. Uh, maybe we'll actually get it.
Usually it takes me like four or five
tries. So, you just kind of hope the
monkey doesn't turn around. Uh, and he
keeps walking, keeps walking, and then
you got to just sprint out of there
quickly. Ow. Damn. Got it first try.
Okay, we got the monkey dentures. Um,
which I have no idea who actually found
those at the first time, but anyway, uh,
we got the dentures. Okay, we're running
through the infinite tunnel of doom with
the monkeys in it. Um, I remember this
being a lot scarier back when I did it
last time. Honestly, protection prayers.
You barely take any damage. No part of
this quest is actually that hard. It's
just a little annoying and frustrating
if you don't actually know what you're
doing. Okay, there we go. We got the
enchanted bar from uh Zul Zulo Zula. I
don't even know. Okay, we're back in the
jail again. Let's see if we can actually
do it the first time.
Uh no. Okay, now we have to use the
enchanted bar on the flames, giving us a
monkey speak amulet. Um yeah, some What
are these flames even doing here? Okay,
so we pretty much finished everything
up. We're on to the boss fight. Um
didn't take me too long. I'm only like
maybe an hour so far to do the rest of
it. Um, if I recall correctly, the boss
fight is a bit of a joke. Uh, you just
kind of protect from
magic, I guess, and you can just range
them. Uh, so we'll see. I don't remember
it being very challenging, though. Yeah,
that was so easy. Kind of disappointing,
actually. Um, but oh well. Not that
disappointing really. I'm kind of glad
it was easy in some ways. But yeah, that
is pretty much the quest complete. We
just have to go back and claim a reward.
All right, there we go, guys. Monkey
Bandis is complete. It got 10k, which we
can add to our cash stack. Awesome
diamonds, but most importantly, access
to a dragon scitar, as well as 35,000
experience in two of my combat skills,
and 20,000 in the other two. Uh, like I
said earlier, we are going to pick
attack and defense to get the majority
of the experience. Uh, just because I
only got my attack to level 28 or sorry,
58. Um, but we'll still get the pretty
hefty amount in strength and hit points
as well. Uh, another notable thing about
getting all these levels is I have
passed level 70 combat. Uh, so I can
actually use the other slayer master
now. Uh, which is nice cuz Vanica has
some pretty crappy tasks. Um, but yeah,
there we go. We're just about to finish
our training and we'll see what levels
we get exactly here several hours later.
Okay, we got 110,000 experience drop
getting us to level 64 strength, 60
attack, and 47 defense. So, that's quite
nice. Uh, worth it just for the
experience. But, of course, we get the
dragon scitar, which is exciting. Uh,
should definitely speed up my training
from now on. So, that is pretty much
going to be the end of the episode,
guys. We're just going to claim our
Grimers and see how much we actually get
in total. So, 7.5 mil where we're ending
the episode. And of course, we have the
dragon scitar, which is exciting. So, we
were plus 55, plus 62, sorry, and now
we're going to be plus 84. So, it was
actually pretty substantial difference.
Uh, so, thanks for watching, guys. I
hope you enjoyed. Uh, if you did, please
remember to stay subscribed. Uh, there
will be a button right on screen. Uh,
just takes a second and you'll stay up
to date with my most recent videos. All
right, guys. See you in the next video.
Bye.
[Music]